ich kann jetzt über die neueste
entwicklung mit dem virologen hendrik
strikt sprechen schon guten abend
franken haben die zahlen so zumindest
erscheint es wenn man die zahlen sich
anschaut explodieren förmlich wir hören
aus der politik warnungen jetzt wirklich
auch das öffentliche leben das private
leben zurück zu fahren
wie nah sind wir denn an einem neuen
allgemeinen stillstand das hängt von der
entscheidung der politik ab ob man einen
stillstand haben will aber würden sie
das raten im augenblick ja also
virologisch muss man ja eigentlich so
was immer raten aber ich selber der es
denke nicht dass wir diesen punkt
erreicht haben denn für mich ist es sehr
viel wichtiger auf die anderen faktoren
auf zu schauen also nicht nur als die
infektionszahlen auch die stationäre
intensivmedizinische belegung muss
genauso geschaut werden weil das
eigentliche geschehen spielt sich in den
krankenhäusern am ende ab
infektionszahlen spiegeln eigentlich
nicht mehr richtig wider was wir zum
beispiel märz und april gehabt haben und
daher müssen wir auf den anderen zahlen
bei anderen werten schwellenwerte
definieren damit wir auch besser
verstehen die das infektionsgeschehen
sich verhält sie haben ja immer sehr
stark dafür plädiert das stärker lokal
und regional sich anzuschauen wir haben
jetzt einen solchen fall in
berchtesgaden etwa dort gibt es einen
stillstand muss das nicht noch forciert
werden damit wir eben nicht allgemein zu
einem stillstand kommen
das problem was sich darin sehe ist dass
man sich solitär die infektionszahlen
anschaut auch in berchtesgaden schaut
man sich solitär die infektionszahlen an
aber nimmt es nicht zusammen mit den
stationären bewegungen und sich
medizinischen belegung weil nur daran
und das kann ja auch bundeseinheitlich
definiert werden aber dann regional die
werte definiert werden das können wir ja
eigentlich verstehen wie das
infektionsgeschehen sich verhält wir
können es auch nicht mit märz oder april
vergleichen weil wir damals sehr viel
weniger getestet hatten
wie wird die weitere entwicklung
aussehen das ist eine glaskugel frage
das ist mir klar aber sie
arbeiten ja ständig mit den zahlen kann
man sagen diese zweite welle die ja
durchaus auch vage er kommentiert worden
ist noch im sommer
die ist eigentlich da wir sind
mittendrin und die wird sich
wahrscheinlich in der oder weise
entwickeln nun dass die zahlen weiter
ansteigen werden das steht außer frage
dass es eben die saisonalität des virus
es wird dann eben auch zum frühjahr
wieder also oder zum sommer hin wieder
abflachen und dann im nächsten herbst
und winter auch wieder hochgehen
die frage dabei ist wie hoch ist jetzt
gehen wird das kann man nicht
vorhersagen vielleicht das mildere
wetter hat jetzt dann vielleicht einen
einfluss den wir dann nächste woche
sehen werden aber wir können es nicht
vorhersagen wie hoch die
infektionszahlen gehen ist brennt ja
auch irgendwann ein wenig aus wenn das
virus nicht mehr so viele findet um zu
infizieren aber das kann wirklich keiner
mehr vorhersagen strikt hört sich das an
vielen dank